von der leyens team in brüssel die
künftige eu kommissionschef in
präsentiert ihre kommissare fast die
hälfte davon sind frauen
rückzug aus der spd-spitze manuela
schwesig gibt wegen einer
brustkrebserkrankung parteiämter auf
ministerpräsidentin will sie bleiben und
iaa in der krise immer weniger
aussteller auf der automobilmesse die
versuchen mit neuen elektro modellen zu
überzeugen
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
barbara hahlweg guten abend und
willkommen zum nachrichtenüberblick an
diesem dienstag norbert lehmann ist auch
dabei für den sport ein schwimmender von
mir fast die hälfte ist weiblich das ist
das erste was an ursula von der leyens
wunschmannschaft in brüssel auf fällt
aus jedem der derzeit noch 28
mitgliedsstaaten kommt ein vertreter
nur großbritannien schickt niemanden die
zukünftige kommissionspräsidentin ordnet
jedem kommissar ein fachgebiet zu
ähnlich den ministerien in nationalen
regierungen über den posten des
kommissars für außen und
sicherheitspolitik haben die eu staats
und regierungschefs bereits gemeinsam
entschieden
es wird der spanier josep borrell
abschließend müssen sich die neuen
kommissare dem europäischen parlament in
anhörungen vorstellen
die mehrheit der parlamentarier muss die
neue eu kommission bestätigen und zwar
als gesamtpaket und das könnte scheitern
denn längst nicht alle kandidaten stoßen
bei den abgeordneten auf zustimmung aus
brüssel gunnar krüger auf diesen zettel
hat brüssel gewartet fein gewichtet nach
partei region geschlecht jeder wunsch
ist erfüllt zugleich aber beschwört die
künftige chefin ihre unabhängigkeit und
die der kommissar
sie sind jetzt europäer die in erster
linie im europäischen interesse handelt
der beweis steht noch aus ursula von der
leyen holt sich drei mächtige
stellvertreter franz zimmermann es für
das klima margarete wester für
digitalisierung und wettbewerb valdis
dombrovskis für wirtschaft viele
einfluss gibt sie auch der tschechien
viradouro war als kommissarin für
grundwerte und polens janusz
wojciechowski als agrarkommissar der ire
phil hogan wird zuständig für handel
also auch für das verhältnis zu
großbritannien nach dem wechsel er wird
ein sehr fairer aber ein entschlossener
verhandler
die thermisch nico schädel die tschechen
euro' war muss dagegen erst beweisen
dass sie ihre nachbarn in osteuropa zur
einhaltung der grundwerte bringt ich
erwarte dass die europäische kommission
auch mit der neubesetzung so klare
signale ausgesandt wird dass diese diese
verteidigung das rechtsstaatsprinzip
auch in der neuen kommission ein top
thema wird sowie von der leyen brauchen
auch kommissare die zustimmung des
eu-parlaments wackelkandidaten sind
schon ausgemacht
zum einen haben wir den ehemaligen
justizminister aus ungarn der also daran
beteiligt war die rechtsstaatlichkeit in
ungarn zu schleifen die polnische
kandidatur ist ebenfalls problematisch
da gibt es finanzielle
unregelmäßigkeiten die dann noch
beleuchtet werden müssen nebenbei
verkündet von der leyen die kommission
tage fortan papierlos was nicht
ausschließt dass sie für die presse
weiter zettel drucken lässt wenn nötig
auch mit neuen namen 14 männer 13 frauen
anne gellinek in brüssel welche zeichen
setzt von der leyen mit diesem kabinett
es in zwei botschaften die ursula von
der leyen mit diesem personaltableau
verbindet wirtschaft nummer eins frauen
an die macht es gibt eine neue super
kommissarin die dänen margrethe vestager
die nicht nur nicht nur ihr machtvolles
dass jedes wettbewerbs behalten hat
sondern eben auch noch digitales dazu
bekommen hat und auch die anderen frauen
in der kommission bekommen durchaus
wichtige ressorts zugeteilt von von der
leyen als da wären binnenmarkt
verteidigung innenpolitik und energie
und eine zweite botschaft geht von
diesem personaltableau aus das ist das
zukunftsaufgaben in dieser kommission
ganz nach vorne gerückt werden neben der
super kommissarin für digitales gibt es
jetzt auch ein super kommissar für klima
der niederländer frans timmermans der
künftig die klimapolitik der
eu-kommission koordinieren soll
also klimaschutz und digitalisierung als
hauptaufgaben wie stehen denn die
chancen dass das europaparlament diese
kandidaten akzeptiert
dass alle durchkommen ist durchaus sehr
unwahrscheinlich denn es ist ja so dass
ein paar kandidaten im verdacht stehen
eu gelder nicht sorgfältig nicht
sorgfältig mit eu geldern umgegangen zu
sein oder auch politisch nicht wirklich
geeignet zu sein zudem ist das
europaparlament immer noch aufgebracht
über die art und weise wie die staats
und regierungschefs ursula von der leyen
im juli aus dem hut gezaubert haben ohne
das parlament mit einzubeziehen und
insofern könnte die befragung der
kommissars kandidaten im parlament eine
gute gelegenheit für die abgeordneten
seien diese kandidaten zu grillen
dankeschön für diese einschätzung aus
brüssel anne gellinek überraschende
personalien aus washington gab es unter
präsident bereits einige seit knapp
einer stunde eine mehr und zwar eine
sehr wichtige
über twitter teilte mit er habe seinen
nationalen sicherheitsberater john boten
entlassen wurden galt als
außenpolitischer hardliner innerhalb der
regierung vor allem mit blick auf den
iran verhandlungen mit dem land lehnt er
rundheraus ab da fragen wir nach bei
emma thompson in washington eigentlich
galt michael bolton doch als vertrauter
des präsidenten warum muss er jetzt
gehen ja schon bald muss gehen weil es
heftigen streit gegeben hat vor einer
woche hier im weißen haus hinter uns gab
es einen krach zwischen ihm und donald
trump um die frage ob die taliban zu
friedensgesprächen nach camp david
eingeladen werden sollen der präsident
wollte das boten sagte auf keinen fall
den kann man nicht trauen
die gespräche sind ja dann wegen eines
terroranschlags in kabul am samstag
abgesagt worden aber gestern abend gab
es dann noch mal einen krach um genau
dieselbe frage und verboten ist dann
zurückgetreten so stellt er das selber
drum sagt er hätte ihn hinausgeworfen
versteht er ist ein hardliner er hat
eine sehr unnachgiebige linie vertreten
gegenüber iran und nordkorea war strikt
dagegen dass deutschland sich mit kim
jong-un trifft und nach nordkorea über
die grenze hinüber geht das was jetzt
passiert ist es eigentlich auch ein
signal dass donald trump im wahlkampf
nicht wirklich an einer eskalation mit
iran und nordkorea interessiert ist und
dass er keine ab
weichen den meinungen zulässt jetzt muss
er sich einen neuen sicherheitsberater
suchen den vierten in drei jahren
und es soll dann sicher einer sein der
weniger widerrede gibt gegenüber dem
präsidenten dankeschön nach washington
oder tee wissen und das ist natürlich
john und nicht mit bunten entschuldigung
nach deutschland soll der bund nach fünf
jahren schwarzer null wieder schulden
machen
dieser ruf nach mehr staatlichen
investitionen wird immer lauter heute
auch im bundestag wo finanzminister
scholz seinen haushaltsentwurf für 2020
präsentierte stolz bin wieder nur das
ausgeben was voraussichtlich eingenommen
wird nämlich knapp 360 milliarden euro
selbst wenn er mehr investieren wollte
beispielsweise in den umweltschutz setzt
ihm das grundgesetz enge grenzen
die schuldenbremse lässt grundsätzlich
im nächsten jahr nur kredite in höhe von
zwölf milliarden euro zu
über den streit patricia wiedemeier als
könne er es kaum erwarten dass
finanzminister scholz am morgen als
erster auf der regierungsbank stolz
präsentierte er dann in der
haushaltsdebatte seinen entwurf
deutschland sei gut gerüstet für alle
herausforderungen die schwarze null
werde auch im dritten haushalt dieser
regierung weiter halten wie die beiden
zuvor ist es ein solider haushalt ohne
neue schulden auskommt trotzdem haben
wir unsere spielräume genutzt
es ist ein expansiver haushalt der viele
investitionen und viele entscheidungen
für die zukunft beinhaltet und das ist
auch richtig so denn wir stehen vor
großen herausforderungen
neue herausforderungen aber ohne neue
schulden auch die union hält vehement an
der schwarzen null fest wir anders als
für andere ist es für uns nicht
irgendeine haushalterischen um events
man nicht mehr passt nur einfach bei
seite legen können sondern ist ein
ausdruck von generationengerechtigkeit
in ein ausdruck für nachhaltigkeit eine
schwarze null obwohl deutlich mehr geld
gebraucht wird für die
klimaschutzmaßnahmen der regierung die
erst noch beschlossen werden müssen
zudem droht ein konjunktureinbruch grüne
und linke halten das klammern an der
schwarzen null für falsch und bekommen
dabei rückendeckung von
wirtschaftsexperten schwarze null war
richtig für die letzten zehn jahre als
wir einen massiven konsolidierungsbedarf
hatten die maastricht kriterien wieder
zu erreichen
jetzt geht es aber darum
deutschland zu modernisieren mit einer
agenda des investierens und dafür
brauchen wir flexibilität dafür brauchen
wir auch eine kreditfinanzierung die
schwarze null ist ein überholtes konzept
wir brauchen dringend investitionen in
zukunftstechnologien insbesondere im
bereich klimaschutz wir haben eine
konjunkturelle rezession vor uns die
zinsen sind niedrig wir sollten jetzt
investieren die diskussion um die
schwarze null sie wird weitergehen
dieser haushalt wird sicherlich nicht so
verabschiedet wie er heute eingebracht
wurde
große betroffenheit hat die krankheit
von manuela schwesig ausgelöst die
ministerpräsidenten von mecklenburg
vorpommern teilte mit dass sie
brustkrebs hat und deswegen ihre ämter
in der bundes-spd aufgibt
ministerpräsidentin und spd
landesvorsitzende will sie aber bleiben
um zeigte sich kämpferisch
viele frauen in deutschland erkranken
jedes jahr an brustkrebs
viele frauen zeigen dass diese schlimme
krankheit halber ist dass man dagegen
ankämpfen kann und ich habe schon einige
kämpfe in meinem leben geführt und werde
auch diesen kampf führen und bin sehr
zuversichtlich dass ich am ende gesund
sein werde
die diagnose brustkrebs ist ein schock
aber tatsächlich sind die
heilungschancen inzwischen ziemlich gut
im keller hat die wichtigsten fakten
brustkrebs ist die mit abstand häufigste
krebsart bei frauen jede achte frau in
deutschland erkrankt im laufe ihres
lebens an brustkrebs
jedes jahr sind das etwa 71.000 die zahl
der brust krebs bedingten todesfälle pro
jahr wird auf etwa 17.500 geschätzt seit
2003 gibt es in deutschland brustzentren
mittlerweile flächendeckend wichtig
früherkennung sofern der krebs noch
nicht gestreut hat gilt er als heilbar
doch auch bei unheilbarem krebs können
zielgerichtete therapien ein langes
überleben sichern
meist wird der tumor operativ entfernt
in 80 prozent der fälle kann die brust
erhalten werden
ganz anderes thema jetzt es gibt
spannungen zwischen china und
deutschland peking beschwert sich dass
es in berlin zu einem treffen zwischen
außenminister maß und dem prominenten
hongkonger bürgerrechtler josua wagen
gekommen ist das sei eine einmischung in
die inneren angelegenheiten der 22
jährige ist einer der köpfe der
demokratiebewegung in hongkong im
heute-journal nachher spricht christian
sievers mit ihm in israel hat eine
ankündigung von ministerpräsident
netanjahu einige aufregung ausgelöst in
einer fernsehansprache sagte er im falle
seiner wiederwahl werde israel das
jordantal im besetzten westjordanland
annektieren
das jordantal im dorf verläuft entlang
der grenze zu jordanien dort leben etwa
60.000 palästinenser und 5000
israelische siedler
das gebiet gilt als verteidigungs
barriere israels aber auch als wichtiges
agrarland der schritt sei mit der us
regierung abgestimmt sagte netanjahu
beobachter sprechen allerdings von einem
wahlkampfmanöver jetzt ein ganz
aktueller blick nach italien dort kann
sich die neue regierung endgültig an die
arbeit machen gerade eben hat sie dafür
auch vom senat grünes licht bekommen
zwar bleibt ihr chef der alte giuseppe
konnte parteilos und auch die fünf
sterne bewegung von luigi die mayo
bleibt in der regierung ausgetauscht
wurde aber ihr koalitionspartner die
rechte leger von matteo salvini ist nach
machtkampf mit den fünf sternen raus die
sozialdemokraten sind dafür drin und die
gelten als freundlich aus rom annette
hilsenbeck
die spannung bleibt bis zum schluss 161
stimmen braucht dieselbe konnte um die
vertrauensfrage zu überstehen
162 hat seine koalition im senat doch es
gibt abweichler in den letzten tagen
hatte konnte daher mit vertretern
kleinerer parteien verhandelt vor
wenigen minuten das ergebnis die
regierung konnte hat es geschafft
konnte spricht heute davon dann in der
flüchtlingspolitik mit brüssel
verhandeln zu wollen
migration muss auf europäischer ebene
gelöst werden
wir müssen zusammen an die arbeit gehen
und die bedingungen des dublin vertrages
verändert amtsvorgänger salvinis
aggressive haltung gegenüber
hilfsorganisationen zumindestens wird
nicht fortgesetzt wie sehr sich die
flüchtlingspolitik ändert hängt jetzt
auch von brüssel ab klar ist diese neue
regierung italiens wird wieder europa
freundlicher das wurde auch bei der
vereidigung am letzten freitag deutlich
die zeit der populistischen attacken aus
rom ist wohl vorbei minister für
wirtschaft wird der bisherige europa
parlamentarier roberto gualtieri er
leitete dort einen wirtschaftsausschuss
stadt gegen eu haushaltsregeln zu
rebellieren wird er wohl eher gewieft
taktieren die rechte legal mit
parteichef matteo salvini ist jetzt in
der opposition
und er machte schon gestern mit einer
großen kundgebung front gegen die neue
regierung
wir werden letztlich gewinnen die können
jetzt vorwahlen wegrennen aber es ist
eine regierung ohne sinn ohne akzeptanz
viel zeit hat premier konnte nicht bis
mitte oktober schon muss die neue
regierung einen haushaltsplan in brüssel
vorlegen
es wird ihre erste bewährungsprobe in
düsseldorf hat es in einem krankenhaus
gebrannt ein 77 jahre alter patient ist
dabei ums leben gekommen
19 menschen wurden verletzt vier
lebensgefährlich durch
rauchgasvergiftungen
das feuer war in der zweiten etage
ausgebrochen von dort aus verteilte sich
der rauch im gesamten gebäude
warum es brannte ist noch unklar die
polizei ermittelt hat die internationale
automobilausstellung in frankfurt ihre
besten zeiten hinter sich heute hat sie
begonnen allerdings mit deutlich weniger
ausstellern als bisher für so fehlt
genau wie citroën volvo 4 tesla und alle
anderen us hersteller auch toyota ist
nicht dabei e mobilitäts konzepte stehen
im mittelpunkt kritiker sagen viel zu
spät wieder theissen über eine iaa die
gegen ihren bedeutungsverlust kämpft
sieht so die zukunft der mobilität aus
oder so auf der iaa scheint man sich
nicht so sicher zu sein
fahrräder prominent auf dem messegelände
viele große autobauer hingegen fehlen
die ja muss ich wirklich neu erfinden um
in der zukunft eine chance zu haben war
einfach autos hintereinander zu stellen
aufstände zu stellen das bewegt heute
weniger die leute auf der iaa den hebel
gerade noch rechtzeitig umlegen in
richtung e-mobilität das wollen opel bmw
mercedes und vw und drücken ihre e autos
in den fokus geld verdienen sie
allerdings mit immer mehr suv es auf den
straßen dagegen regt sich protest
am wochenende wollen aktivisten die ira
sogar lahmlegen
wie es für uns ein symbol ort das ist
eine glitzer und glanz messe wo sich
eben die spitzen aus industrie und
politik treffen um sich für ein
verkehrssystem von vorvorgestern zu
feiern heute ein kleiner vorgeschmack
stiller protest gegen die
klimaschädliche suvs der druck wächst
auf die iaa auch angesichts ziemlich
leere hallen
doch von einem möglichen aus für die
messe will der verband der autoindustrie
nichts wissen wir haben weniger
aussteller wir haben auch weniger fläche
aber wir haben ein breites spektrum an
der gesamten wertschöpfungskette und
technologien hier vertreten um das thema
zukunft der mobilität hier erlebbar zu
machen
die alte iaa als reine große show der
schönen und schnellen autos die ist wohl
vergangenheit
erleichterung bei den fußball hast die
nationalmannschaft gerade noch einmal
die kurve gekriegt in der
em-qualifikation gegen wie sagt man da
doch so schön durch einen arbeitssieg
und da hatten joachim löws kicker in
belfast wirklich jede menge arbeit gegen
einen aggressiven und leidenschaftlich
kämpfenden gegner am ende zählt nur das
ergebnis zwei zu null gewonnen und
tabellenführung weniger furchterregend
als mancher fan aber doch ziemlich
irritierend war das forechecking der
notieren es produzierte fehlpässe manuel
neuer als letzte instanz hielt die null
die umgebaute deutsche abwehr geriet vor
der pause mehr als einmal ins schwimmen
das spiel erinnerte zuweilen an dass
holland match aber es war besser
es war besser es war besser
nicht nur aber auch seinetwegen marcel
halstenberg ein kunstschuss des
leipziger linksverteidigers in einer
starken viertelstunde nach der pause
brachte das dfb-team auch die
vielzitierte siegerstraße im training
probiert man alles das sowas dann im
spiel passiert und es bis heute gelungen
es blieb ein holpriger weg bis zum 2 0
in der nachspielzeit durch sabri dem
auffälligsten deutschen glänzen konnten
sie nicht aber harte arbeit reicht
zuweilen auch erster tag der parade im
dm und erste medaille für die deutsche
mannschaft gestern am späten abend in
london
verena schott holt silber über 100 meter
brust zwei deutsche im finale über die
100 meter brust
die kleinwüchsige perry sonntag und
gleich daneben verena schott die auf
dieser strecke 2015 weltmeisterin
geworden ist die 30 jährige zweifache
mutter fünfter nicht in der von ihr
erhofften zeit muss sich aber letztlich
nur der ukrainerin elisabeth amerika
geschlagen geben
ich wollte auf jeden fall die medaille
auch gerne etwas schneller geschwommen
aber diese silberne muss nicht die
einzige medaille für verena schott
bleiben denn sie wird in london noch in
zwei weiteren disziplinen an den start
gehen
hier habe ich heute nicht aber ich
nämlich bilder aus einem pool in
schwaibach im saarland die uns zum
schmunzeln brachten dort gab es ein
großes sommer schluss finale für hunde
ausnahmsweise durften am letzten tag der
freibadsaison die vierbeiner ins becken
eine seltene chance die offenbar nicht
alle kandidaten sofort restlos
begeistert aber 15 grad außentemperatur
und trotzdem das schwimmbad voll mit
zahlenden zuschauern keine ganz
schlechte idee
beim wetter ring im gerade sommer und
herbst miteinander morgens neblig
tagsüber zum teil richtig sonnig wo es
weht und regnet erklärt gleich katja
horneffer im heute journal um zettel vor
10 begrüßt sie christian sievers wir
wünschen ihnen noch einen unbeschwerten
abend und sind morgen wieder da wenn sie
lust haben auf wiedersehen
[Musik]
meine damen und herren zurzeit kämpfen
sommer und herbst miteinander das heißt
morgens ist es zum teil richtig nämlich
dann kommt die septembersonne und den
nebel einfach weg und dann gibt es meist
nur kleine schöne quellwolken die
konnten sie heute zum beispiel auch von
der zugspitze sehen da hat es ja am
wochenende geschneit da ist es also
leicht überzuckert mit etwas schnee kein
schnee fällt in der nacht sondern
ähnlich wie auch über tag an der ostsee
noch etwas regen sonst ist es häufig
klar und es bildet sich auch wieder
nebel temperaturen sinken auf werte
zwischen 12 und 2 grad örtlich droht
also wieder bodenfrost und morgen
erwarten uns dann höchsttemperaturen
zwischen 18 grad an der nordsee und 23
grad zum beispiel in sachsen
der tag beginnt nach nebel erst mal sehr
freundlich das wird sich aber bald
ändern denn dann kommen von nordwesten
dichtere wolken heran und spätestens
nachmittags kann es dann zwischen sylt
und dem emsland regnen und auch aus den
alpen heraus sind zum abend einige
regenschauer zu erwarten
am donnerstag gibt es regen dann
allenfalls noch in den westlichen
mittelgebirgen am freitag am ehesten an
der ostseeküste
danach wird es spätsommerlich für alle
schönen abend noch